وقد ابلغت ولايه فلوريدا وزاره العدل
الامريكيه ان مراقبي التصويت الفيدراليين
لن يسمح لهم بدخول مراكز الاقتراعي في
الولايه وكاله الوزاره وقد اعلنت في وقت
سابقا عن خطط لمراقبه الامتثال لقوانين
حقوق التصويت الفيدراليه في 64 دائره
انتخابيه في 24 ولايه وذكرت وزاره العدل
ان قسم الحقوق المدنيه سيتلقى شكاوى من
الجمهور على مستوى البلاد فيما يتعلقوا
بالانتهاكات المحتمله لقوانينه حقوق
التصويت وقالت الوزاره ان من بين
المراقبين موظفين من قسم الحقوق المدنيه
ومن مكاتب النيابه العامه في الولايات هذا
وساينشر قسم المراقبين من مكتب اداره شؤون
الموظفين
سينشر بامر من المحاكم الفيدراليه كما
سيبقى افراد القسم على اتصال مع مسؤولي
الانتخابات على مستوى الولايات والمجالس
المحليه